Have you ever been to Paris?
If you have, you would agree that there is something romantic and glittering about Paris.
Likewise, if you visit Beirut in Lebanon, the unique atmosphere is something that will captivate you.
The blend of peoples, cultures and religions gives the city a special vibrancy and energy that is second to none.
People watching is a fascinating form of sightseeing, and the best place to enjoy it is from the corniche.
Outdoor cafes in downtown Beirut can also be a perfect place.
The historical downtown area, damaged during the civil war, has been renovated.
In addition, if you want to have great views of the coast, visit the seaside promenade...
...from where you have a good view of Pigeon Rocks.
These dramatic rock formations in a cove will make a perfect background for your evening drinks.
Don't forget to stop there and enjoy a beverage.